I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not
oh hi mark I love my eyes tiny anything
that's what time
Wow
one of my most requested titles to talk
about in the hilarious 'ti format has
been samurai cop now that I've seen it I
understand why it's barely even a movie
this thing wasn't even released in
theaters it went straight to VHS at some
point then just got buried by obscurity
eventually it was rediscovered and now
it is one of the best worst movies of
all time and oh my god having seen it I
can see why I first heard about this
movie from my buddy fanboy flicks he did
a really funny review of it and I was
like huh that movie looks movie looks
special so I decided to check it out
myself
I don't even know where to begin I
really there's just there's so much shit
to talk about there's so much crap this
movie is unimaginably terrible it fails
it everything but my god it is
entertaining to watch so let's start
talking about the beginning of samurai
cop from the very beginning the opening
title music sounds like a Sega Genesis
game
if you watch this movie one of the
things you'll probably notice is that
every single scene takes place in
daylight and that's because the
filmmaker wasn't able to afford lighting
to shoot at night so every single scene
in this movie is during the day and they
obviously have no idea what exposure is
because many shots go back and forth
drastically changing exposure color time
of day Sun position everything it
honestly looks like the entire film was
shot on one of those gigantic VHS
camcorders like the ones your grandpa
used to have also prevalent in this
movie is some of the most horrendous
dubbing I've ever heard in my life in no
way we go under he almost black yeah
that right there that electronic warble
that's because the director dubbed a lot
of the lines himself because he couldn't
get the actors back in to do it and so
he recorded a lot of the dialogue
himself and then tried to warp it in
weird ways to make it seven different
the basic plot of samurai cop if there
even is one is there's a gang that is
into drugs and this cop who's recently
come to the area who is known as samurai
because apparently he speaks fluent
Japanese despite not being able to say
Japanese names correctly so anyway you
get on the phone and you tell me that
these what's his name Omaha Yamaha
whatever his faces name is right are you
food Fujiyama as well as this scene what
does katana me means Japanese sword just
where do I start what do I fucking start
with this thing the movie mercifully
lets us know what the actions gonna be
like pretty early on with this
horrendously choreographed and
incredibly fake fight scene but it's all
the more hilarious for it are you sure
this is a good bust
yeah okay
we're gonna go catch us some bad guys
yeah a nice wig man that's another thing
to keep in mind apparently the entire
film was shot or at least the lead actor
thought so so he cut his hair the
director then told him we need to do
some reshoots but he had cut all of his
hair so they had to find a wig and all
they could get was this incredibly
feminine wig and to the incredible
horror of the lead actor they still had
about half the film to shoot so he goes
from ladies wig to actual hair quite
often also heavily prevalent in this
movie is absurd sexism I mean every
woman in this movie looks like a porn
star even random background people who
are just walking around they all look
like they came off of a 1989 porn shoot
and every single time samurai cop is in
a scene with a woman he is always trying
to get in her pants oh it's up and ready
you just keep it warm it's for men so
samurai cop and his partner are going
after these drug guys and by the way I
can't help but notice that these guys
look remarkably like the lethal weapon
pair Mel Gibson and Danny Glover and
this movie was being filmed only a few
years after Lethal Weapon came out so
all I can think of is that the director
saw Lethal Weapon said that was amazing
let's recreate it and now we have
samurai cop so the second action scene
is this incredibly inept chase scene
samurai cop and his partner are chasing
this van filled with druggies and my god
it is just filled with way too many
hilarious moments to even mention you
just have to see them
hey man watch it watch it oh man I don't
know where do I fucking start where do
and the best part of this whole thing is
when the van driver catches on fire
he clearly changes ethnicities yeah
that's the same guy a large majority of
the sequences samurai cop just saying
shoot him shoot him over and over again
my favorite part my favorite part is
when he's like oh you got him to shoot
him shoot you got it yeah I got the bed
where do I start
and this leads us into our very first
porn scene and I'm not kidding I mean
it's distance porn I mean the camera
lingers on her body for absurd amounts
of time and then we get what has become
known as the piano on the head scene I
want his head cut off and brought here I
want his head on this piano I will bring
you his head and I will place it on your
piano I will bring you his head and I
will place it on your piano right around
here I started to notice that almost
every close-up has an absurd amount of
space above their heads it's almost like
the director told the cinematographer or
the cinematographer did this on his own
to perfectly Center the head that's not
how it works the guy's it's not out work
close-ups the forehead has nothing
interesting okay close-ups usually start
right above the eyebrow but almost every
close-up in this movie has like this
crazy amount of space above the hairline
it's so ugly I gotta be honest the next
scene in this movie involving a nurse is
one of the most insane things I've ever
seen in my life and I mean that in all
honesty all I can do is basically mimic
my reactions to having watched this and
that's the best way I can let you know
what I thought
do you like what you see I love what I
see would you like to touch me
see yes yes I would would you like to go
out with me
uh-huh yes I would
would you like to fuck me
bingo well then let's see what you've
got
doesn't interest me nothing there
nothing there just exactly what would
interest you something the size of a
jumbo jet have you been circumcised
yeah I have why well you dr. mr. cut a
big portion of it ah no he he was a good
doctor good doctors make mistakes too
that's why he's my insurance hey don't
worry I got enough
it's big I want bigger you have got to
be fucking kidding me
his partners reactions everything about
that scene it's just insanity so the
gang sends the swordsman to cut off the
burnt guy's head because there isn't one
time to talk and then we get this weird
escape scene that has two cuts from the
exact same hallway laced right next to
each other and in the following scene we
get count'em for hey wait a minutes hey
wait a minute
ah wait a minute wait a minute doctor
another thing has become famous about
this movie is that legend says that
nearly every scene was just done with
one take and they almost always use that
very first take and here when we get her
introduction to the captain and he
floods up his line like this you're the
one that talked me into bringing this
moron from San Diego the point that
Japanese get done again I have a feeling
that legend is true
but I gotta say I love this captain he
is like the best angry police captain
ever and he says some really crazy shit
feel like somebody stuck a big club up
my ass and it hurts I've got to figure
out a way to get him out of there
all right the scene also ends with a
very elongated bizarre pause yeah you
son of a bitch come back here you
motherfucker
so now we get to the restaurant scene
which is iconic for good reason there
are just so many incredible things
happening in this scene and one thing
you'll notice is that as samurai cop is
approaching this table of gang members
this conversation breaks out and you can
so tell these shots were filmed in
different locations back and forth and
different times and with different
lights and everything but this scene
contains hands-down one of the best one
shot one take insults I've ever seen
now I'm telling me son of a bitches that
we respect the Japanese of this country
who are honest businessmen and yeah this
is the land of opportunity for
legitimate business not for death
merchants who distribute drugs to our
children through schools and on the
streets
now I'm telling these motherfuckers that
if they continue killing our children to
make their precious Millions that they
deposit in their secret Swiss bank
accounts counselor before your lawsuit
even gets off the court clerk's desk
I'll have their stinking bodies and
garbage bags and ship them back to Japan
for fertilizer got it
now I'm telling these son of a bitches
these motherfuckers if they keep killing
our children and the finale this scene
is so great as well as samurai cops
partner laughing and saying this hey
counselor we'll see you in court
the scene also ends with the most random
encounter with a waiter I've ever seen
in a movie well shot him he who him
who's him himself
oh he committed suicide yes what is the
purpose what's happening here what does
this mean now another incredibly random
action scene erupts outside of this
restaurant samurai cop chops off this
guy's arm
it's amazing the choreography here I
mean like what choreography it's just a
bunch of huh sure sure look but hey I
mean at least it ends with a great joke
kept the Romans gonna burn my ass yeah
he's gonna burn it charcoal black
it is black rat oh I don't know what to
say where do I start and again I gotta
say the captain best angry captain of
all time you get your ass out of my
office or you'll have to go to surgery
to get my foot out of it get out of here
you asshole leave me alone I'll see you
in court
you motherfucker I'll see you in hell
leave me alone get a job so again
samurai cop has one thing on his mind
and he comes off like a samurais stalker
in this scene he just really likes this
blonde chick he saw at that restaurant
decides to follow her around because he
really wants to get in her pants and
this scene ends with another incredibly
pointless fight scene and this guy
swinging that bat it's I can't I've
constantly in shock I'm constantly in
shock this movie got made they made this
somebody made it take that as
inspiration everyone out there with
great ideas samurai cop got made I'm
reviewing samurai cop if you have an
idea it's probably better than samurai
cop and you can probably direct and
write it better than samurai cop was
written and directed so be inspired
people this movie got made and again the
women in this movie the only reason
women are in this movie are for samurai
cop to fuck them or for them to walk
around and look sexy or for them to do
something that the people who made this
movie think women do all the time
seriously look at this line hey preacher
yeah you and I got nothing to do let's
fuck later when we're introduced to this
character again where is she she's in
the kitchen of course seriously
everything about women in this movie is
like the most sexist viewpoint of a
woman you could possibly have it's kind
of sad it's really sad actually so now
this raid occurs on this house they're
trying to find the rest of these gang
members and the biggest star of this
action scene is the defender arcade
machine because the hardcore drug
dealers they really love their defender
I mean it is really fun this leads us
into another
horrible fight scene that's just
everything about it's amazingly awful
but it's entertaining and his wig
I gotta say this is one of the most
obvious wig scenes now another terrible
shootout scene with a very hilarious
t-shirt wig and hat happens and it cuts
incredibly abruptly to this
I mean my god the dubbing here the ADR
is so horrendous excuse me
where did the tall guy with the ponytail
go
the samurai cop basically forces this
girl to go on a date with him by
stalking her the church that she goes to
and then pretending like he had to
question her about this gang but in
reality he's just taking her back to his
house so they can get dressed in the
most late 80s Early 90s swimsuits I've
seen in so long and just prance around
the beach for a while so now the gang is
looking for samurai cop and they somehow
find all of his associates I don't know
how they just do hey take it easy good
come on talk to me what do you I gonna
kill you now but I can believe you this
gift it's black gift I mean I don't know
what else to expect at this point the
abrupt shifts in tone in samurai cop are
some of my favorite parts of this movie
because it goes from like guys
threatening to cut off somebody's dick
to this happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you okay
I'll take it I'll take it and we get
another porno sex scene
seriously this goes on forever and it's
not sexy it's incredibly awkward
actually it's very bizarre and just
off-putting
and even slightly embarrassing you're
almost picturing them behind the camera
like slowly touching themselves like oh
this is sex no don't cut just yet don't
cut not just yet not just yet not just
yet okay okay you can come down so
there's a shootout scene in which
samurai cop and this girl are almost
killed and in the very following scene
he's like not even remotely affected by
this she's just prancing around her home
she's smiling she's all excited she has
a new boyfriend she almost got killed
like five minutes ago whatever so the
captain gets really angry again and
gives samurai cop and his partner
permission to just go kill every
wani literally says his go kill everyone
for me do it for me they're like okay
cool all right sounds good to me man
yeah and we get another horrendous
action scene now I gotta say at least
50% of this movie is people ducking for
cover and then shooting and then ducking
for cover and then shooting
that's all this movie is and I just want
to know like in their desperate search
for actors when they found this guy did
they hire him because they thought he
would be really good at dying on screen
because if they did they failed
so in the big finale scene with the boss
he's holding the woman hostage there's a
moment where samurai cops partner could
have taken care of business and it's
this moment now that she loves you you
would have to worry about her life not
me neither do i but he lets him know
he's there he could have had the jump on
him why what a dumbass and he gets shot
but of course he's wearing a bulletproof
vest because you know he's the main
character and he got shot so he's
obviously wearing a bulletproof vest
so after killing the boss of this gang
they show up at the last bad guys house
somehow now I've been waiting for there
to be a reason for this movie to be
called samurai cop for quite some time
so gratefully some random goon just
walks up to them with a sword while the
two cops have guns this guy's just like
swinging the sword around and of course
they kill the guy with the sword so it's
a really good thing that samurai cop can
then pick up that sword and actually do
something samurai like and fight this
last guy and the way they swing their
swords it's so obviously sped up and sad
these people are desperate they're just
like just get it done okay just film the
fucking movie so I can go home and go to
bed and I can't help but notice that
samurai cop really looks like Rambo here
this movie is basically like an
amalgamation of 80s action movies that
were good and then the director was like
I'm gonna try to remake those the
samurai cop wins of course and the guy
kills himself because honour because
after being a drug dealer and a murderer
and a guy who tortures women he's really
concerned about honor so we get more
swimsuits and the movies over wow I I
had no words when I watched this movie
guys I mean you've been recommending
this for quite some time and you've been
wanting to see a hilarious 'ti of this
and I had no idea what to expect
timmreck up honestly changed my life I
don't even know what to think or do or
expect this movie has changed everything
everything's different now samurai cop
you you broke me never
samurai cup uh check it out sometime I
guess I'm gonna have another hilarious
tea for you very soon on Valentine's Day
in fact and that's going to be with my
wife it's going to be a special
hilarious 'ti and I cannot wait to bring
it to you guys
it's another review you guys have been
requesting surprisingly for a while that
I had no desire to do and then I just
went wait Valentine's Day is coming up
perfect
I can't wait to bring that to you guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
you